i hope like when you know a seinfeld or
a big act would come into town i was in
arizona
if you're open middle on the road or a
headliner it was all sort of like
not the same but everyone would just
[ __ ] and so whenever you're on the
road you're like
hey i just work with this guy who is
your middle oh it's good
and everyone sort of knew each other
over the years that everyone and you
just realize you're all in the same
racket now
but there's like a fraternity
club to that that you just sort of with
comics i start liking them until proven
otherwise so i'll just say hey man hey
man
until someone rubs me wrong or they
don't like me or whatever
but overall i just get a lot you know i
will start by
being cool because when i was on the way
up people were pretty cool and you just
wanted them to hey you know
like tell me about being a headliner or
ask questions about [ __ ]
so it's fun because usually everyone you
talk to you start
bullshitting about some comic you worked
with or do you know this guy and
you know some of their jokes you talk
about to repeat every one of those
jokes it's fun i like that so i like the
comedy world
so adami brought me into the comedy
store because i saw him
she goes you should do sets here i never
did a set there because i auditioned
when i before snl and i didn't get it
with mitzi
i just was 20. mitzi and mitsy said now
louis anderson got me in cut the tape
um what happened no
no louie got me in he just knew
schneider or something i knew i knew
robin he got me an audition
and she and he walked out the sidewalk
right there on sunset i'm like so
nervous
yeah she didn't like you god damn and i
thought i did good
funny boys got me in at the improv which
is comedy team
and they said they told me to start
getting spots so i said okay
so anyway that's how it started but i
never went back to the comedy store
because of that
yeah you know i steve harvey one time i
saw him walk in because he was doing
like
fat tuesday which was a you know
it was called fat tuesday yeah fat
tuesday it was on tuesday nights and it
was um
and there's i'm gonna say this word and
i don't want to get in trouble for it
but this is what they call it
no it was called urban comedy night whoa
that's what it was called i can't
believe you said that
it was also chocolate sundae exactly
right
[Laughter]
is that the belly room it was no it was
in the main room so you know
cedric and all these guys so i remember
steve harvey
came walked in to the building and he
spit
on the wall down the hall i'm not
kidding you
down the hallway he goes [ __ ] this
[ __ ] club
[ __ ] mitzi shore try to audition for
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
so people have you know when mitsy ran
it this resentment i was at a
i've said this before i was sat next to
mitzi during
a showcase and this guy came out she was
killing
right and a minute in she goes lighter
he doesn't have it he doesn't and i go
um mitzi that's louis c.k has his hbo
special
he was just doing like a guest spot no
he was showcasing
oh and she she looks at me she goes he
doesn't have it
oh boy i go he doesn't have what
no talent yes you know what i mean i
mean it was i know no matter what you
say about me you got to say he writes
good job
he's so he was so funny that night but
mitzi is just um
i never met her i never saw her in my
life yeah he was in the back
maybe or whatever that was maybe pitch
black [ __ ] dirty comedy store yeah
which it might get a good scrubbing
while they're out
adam while you're in there let's get the
scrubbing bubbles in there and uh really
give it a
but do you like the club i do like it
because i never really out of resentment
i didn't know anyone i didn't know how
to get spots and i just said [ __ ] i wish
i had a place to practice
and then i met adam through whatever and
then he goes should come down i don't
know
so i went down and he goes i'll give you
a spot whatever so i walk he goes just
come in whatever so i went in one night
and he was just go next
and then i came in a week later he goes
just go next and then i go oh i don't
want to bump then i
was turning into bumping yeah i go uh
i'll just tell you ahead and you're just
throwing me on the lineup and then
i don't want to be one of these guys so
uh because you were one of those people
that like because we had the same old
[ __ ] before adam
because i've been there since 1995. oh
really
oh yeah i was a doorman i did the whole
[ __ ] time oh [ __ ] okay
yeah so it's like when i'd seen the same
axe
for 15 years she never invited
new people in right he put together a
good squad oh my god he brought because
those lineups
are
taking a break those lineups are this
problem is your chair like whenever you
sit on it it just starts to spin
you want a green one no okay
this looks pretty good i'm gonna try to
jam it so it doesn't keep spinning yeah
yeah whatever you know
yeah uh back to this can you hear me now
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah what are you doing george
yeah those lineups are insane